should King Charles invite Megan and
Harry to the coronation you're going to
be there
I had a feeling you might ask me that so
look you you know you know I can't talk
about the royal family but what I can
say is one of the great privileges of
this job is spending time with the
Monarch and also championing what is an
amazing British institution should
people who came in the world should
people who keep trashing the royal
family monarchy just shut up look I said
it's one of the proudest parts of my job
is to go around the world and champion
and celebrate British institutions like
the Royals Australians have just taken
all the rules off their stamps yeah but
you know what there's an enormous amount
of affection for the royal family
everywhere I go around the world and
they do an incredible Job King Charles
does an incredible job we're lucky to
have him the coronation is going to be
superb and we're going to have a great
time and you don't mind if you're next
to Megan and O'Hara I again
what I'm focused on to make sure we have
a great time as a country